in 2020 cardi b sued youtube vlogger
tasha k for defamation invasion and
privacy and intentional infliction of
emotional distress now the verdict is in
and cardi b is looking like a moneybag
moneybag moneybag i love it when we do
these on singers the jury ordered tasha
k to pay 1.25 million dollars for
defamation of character 1.5 million
dollars in punitive damages and 1.3
million dollars to cover cardi b's legal
fees i guess when cardi b said spoil me
and prada i'm worth every dollar
she apparently meant it now we've talked
about defamation many times on this
channel specifically about how hard it
is for public figures to win a
defamation lawsuit well credit to cardi
b and her lawyers they successfully
proved that tasha k made false claims
and did them with actual malice if this
verdict holds up cardi b is gonna buy a
palace tasha k made claims with actual
malice if this verdict holds up cardi's
gonna buy a palace
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a youtube lawyer that's kind of fun so
just what is the beef between cardi b
and tasha k is this the greatest legal
fight between someone who uses their
first name and the last initial how did
cardi's lawyers convince a jury that she
had been defamed and what did tashike
argue in defense well listen up because
you're about to get a master class in
how cardi b bossed up and changed the
game
okay so let's talk about the beef
between cardi b and tasha k youtuber
latasha kebay also known as tasha k is a
popular podcast host vlogger and blogger
she posts interviews and opinion pieces
on her youtube channel unwind with tasha
k she has over a million subscribers and
also hosts a streaming service called
tashaklive.com
now on september 19 2018 tasha published
a video of an interview she conducted
with star marie jones jones claimed that
she had been roommates with cardi b
during cardi's stripper days jones told
tasha that cardi had prostituted herself
to make a living before she became a rap
superstar jones
said she lived with cardi and knew for a
fact that cardi got herpes but as far
back as 2018 there was evidence that
star marie jones was not who she claimed
to be before she went viral by claiming
to be cardi's ex-roommate jones said
that she actually did not know cardi but
felt jealousy over cardi's record deal
later she apparently concocted a story
about knowing cardi tasha then repeated
jones claims on all of her social media
channels should tasha have believed star
marie's story well another youtuber
impressive says no impressive figured
out that jones lied way back in 2018. in
her video she revealed that jones
admitted she had never met cardi and
points out that star marie is very
bitter that her own music career never
took off here impressive shows a clip of
jones meeting with tasha impressive says
that she felt sorry that tasha fell for
jones lies but she felt like it was
important to be responsible about whose
stories vloggers choose to promote
nevertheless over the next three years
toshike repeated the jones claims in at
least 38 videos about cardi b she also
discussed them during instagram live
recordings and on facebook none of those
videos portrayed cardi b in a positive
light and of course because of the first
amendment that's okay in america you can
express your own negative opinion about
someone else as long as you don't make
up false statements about them you can
even call them names so did tasha k
cross the line between defamation and
opinion well it depends on the details
of the actual statements but here's how
the beef went down well first on
september 19 2018 tasha published a
video of herself discussing the jones
video it was titled exclusive cardi b's
ex-friend alleges cardi b kept a huge
box filled with monistat and reveals
more the video got 4 million views cardi
b's lawyer sent a cease and desist
letter to tasha demanding immediate
removal of the video tasha then doubled
down on her claims publishing a video
entitled actual proof cardi b knew her
ex-roommate drake funky deniva vs tamara
and beyonce black magic where she stated
that everything said in the september
19th video was true this is an important
shift in perspective originally tasha
attributed jones as the source for the
sordid allegations about cardi's past
and in terms of news reporting you often
get more protection in a defamation
context when you're simply reporting
what someone else has said compared to
things that you yourself have said
however in the september 19th video
tasha k said everything that we said
that jones said was accurate so did this
set tasha on a course that she found
hard to back down from well on december
18 2018 she published a video on youtube
entitled tatcha k responds to cardi b's
defamation suit and offset's dad calling
cardi b out and more in this video tasha
alleged that when she was a stripper
cardi b used a beer bottle too
uh well you can see what that says then
on january 25th 2019 tasha tweeted that
cardi b had herpes the tweet prompted
cardi to formally request a retraction
and repudiation of these statements
although tasha temporarily removed the
videos and posts by september of 2021
she had relisted and reposted the videos
in the meantime tasha continued to
repeat allegations about prostitution
and herpes and videos and instagram live
sessions on april 23 2019 tasha
published a video on youtube called
tasha k responds to cardi b's mute black
blog's agenda cardi calls shade room
owner a water buffalo i don't know what
any of these things mean this is not my
preferred videos on youtube but
hopefully you can parse what's going on
here in other videos and on instagram
and facebook post
tasha made these claims again and again
just like she did with the other
allegations she also claimed cardi was a
cheater who had contracted the hpv virus
there's more but by now you kind of get
the point tasha k did not like cardi b
and was making lots of serious
allegations about cardi's life as a
stripper now i think it's important to
point out that yes cardi b was a
stripper she's given canyon interviews
about that time in her life and raps
about it however being a stripper isn't
a get out of liability card for tasha k
which brings us to the complaint at
issue on march 21 2019 cardi b sued
tasha kay in star marie jones in the u.s
district court for the northern district
of georgia although defamation and
invasion and privacy are state law
claims the case was filed in federal
court because the plaintiff and
defendant live in different states and
the amount in controversy was over 75
thousand dollars this is called
diversity jurisdiction now jones chose
not to defend herself in the lawsuit so
a new york supreme court judge granted
cardi's motion for default judgment i'm
not going to go into why this is in new
york court at the moment but as part of
that judge's order the video was removed
and jones was prohibited from talking
about the defamatory statements about
cardi in the future the judge's order
explicitly states that as a matter of
law the defendant's statements that
plaintiff had engaged in prostitution
and has or had herpes are held to be
defamatory as they are untrue and were
made without justification or privileged
by defendant now the default judgment
against jones put tasha kay in a
precarious position cardi alleged that
tasha made the following defamatory
statements cardi b was a prostitute
cardi b had certain stis cardi b
performed certain sexual acts and cardi
b took cocaine and ecstasy now tasha
published these statements on her social
media sites gathering millions of views
and likes cardi alleged that they
damaged her reputation in the industry
with her fans and disrupted potential
business relationships now tasha kate
denied that she had defamed cardi she
alleged that all the statements were
true and that they were not made with
actual mouse she argued that she had the
right to rely on jones's original claims
now cardi b's first and main claim was
for defamation we've covered defamation
many times but you generally prove that
by showing four elements a false
statement was made about the plaintiff
the statement was published where other
people saw or heard it the statement
harmed the plaintiff's reputation and no
privilege or defense existed for the
statement and georgia law basically
tracks our basic understanding of
defamation and of course you have to
have this certain mental state generally
it's negligence about the falsity of the
statements but when you're dealing with
someone like a celebrity you have to
have actual mouse which means you
knowingly or recklessly said these false
things that's the higher standard
doesn't have anything to do with
actually not liking a person actual
mouse is about knowingly or recklessly
repeating these false statements and of
course truth is a defense to defamation
in other words defamatory statements
must be false to be actionable you can
say something mean about someone that
hurts their reputation as long as what
you say is accurate or it's you know
opinion or other things that don't rise
to the level of defamation and here
there was no question that the
statements were published and
disseminated to third parties but the
questions of whether a particular
communication was defamatory and whether
the defendant had the requisite mental
state were for the jury to decide now
here the mental state is really
interesting because usually you only
have to prove negligence but following
in a famous supreme court case new york
times versus sullivan when you're
dealing with a public figure you have to
prove actual malice in the sullivan case
the supreme court held that public
official could not recover damages for
defamatory statements regarding his or
her official conduct unless it was
proven that the statement was made with
actual malice which again is a legal
term of art that has nothing to do with
hatred of a person it's about the mental
state of knowing that the the statements
are false later the supreme court
extended the actual malice rule to apply
to criticism of a public figure public
figures are people who are intimately
involved in the resolution of important
public questions or by reason of their
fame shape events in areas of concern to
society at large basically the supreme
court thought that if it was too easy to
prove defamation then rich and
influential people as well as government
officials could use their power to chill
free speech and that could certainly be
a concern in a case like this since an
extremely famous person who presumably
has lots of money
sued someone who has presumably fewer
resources and this is why tasha k called
out cardi b for attempting to silence
her voice as a blogger on the other hand
vloggers like tasha k have pretty big
platforms to spread malicious gossip and
these days everyone has access to the
internet where these things can be
repeated so her success in social media
made her a bigger target than someone
who doesn't have a big social media
presence now this wasn't necessarily an
easy case the judge in cardi b's case
concluded that there was a genuine
dispute of material fact about whether
all of tasha k's statements were in fact
false and defamatory and that it was
going to be up to the jury to decide
these questions for example in this case
cardi denied ever being a prostitute or
using drugs however tasha k offered
evidence that during interviews cardi
had talked about engaging in sexual acts
in exchange for money in that same video
cardi b discusses her use of drugs and
about having to pop pills sometimes when
necessary what does it mean to pop pills
does this imply that she popped cocaine
and molly or that she took benadryl and
tylenol the jury's job was to review all
the evidence and decide whether these
statements were false so let's talk
about the evidence regarding stis juries
who hear civil cases review quite a lot
of evidence and here's a list of the
exhibits submitted in to the court in
this particular case there are 1021
exhibits now the jury didn't hear hours
of testimony on each of these exhibits
but they did have access to all this
material which card to be alleged proved
the elements of her claims and here's
tasha k's list of exhibits she offered
125 exhibits in an attempt to prove that
what she said was true about cardi b and
although we aren't privy to the jury's
deliberations we do know that tasha
failed to prove that her comment about
cardi b having stis was true in
discovery tasha asked for an order
requiring cardi to turn over her medical
records cardi had already submitted sti
tests but did not fight the order the
judge granted her request to produce
material under protective order that
means that the judge can see the medical
records but that they are sealed from
public view and when you're talking
about medical records that makes perfect
sense and in december the judge reviewed
cardi's medical records and ruled that
they did not show that cardi had any
stis
the court has received and reviewed the
records and finds that they are not
helpful to defend it accordingly the
court will file the records under seal
at plaintiff's request only the court
will release the records to both sides
to be used at trial otherwise the record
shall not be opened except with
permission of the district judge or the
court of appeals and then there's
evidence about lying under oath why
didn't tasha kay have more credibility
with the jury well she was caught lying
on the stand on cross-examination tasha
k was asked isn't it a fact that you
testified in your deposition that you
were not a journalist answer yes so when
you told your subscribers that you were
a journalist you were lying answer yes
and when tasha told her viewers that her
lawyer friend had reviewed cardi's
season desist letter and that it was
bogus she was also lying under
cross-examination she said that the
person was just a friend not a lawyer
this by the way is called impeachment of
a witness and it can be incredibly
devastating she was also asked isn't it
true that you lied in your deposition
when you provided a date when you put up
a video defaming my client answer i made
up a date because you were being
combative towards me tasha's husband
also kind of threw her under the bus
asked is it true your wife lied when she
said that there are several businesses
under kb studios answer yes
journalist dennis byron a contributor to
tmz live tweeted the trial he revealed
that tasha's husband refuted her
testimony four times and then of course
there is the evidence about actual
malice here the jury must have found
that tashike acted with actual mouse
that is that she made statements with
knowledge that it was false or with
reckless disregard of whether it was
false or not what evidence did the jury
have to show that tasha
shouldn't have relied on jones and the
other statements well cardi's lawyers
had videos where tasha conceded that she
repeated things that she knew
weren't really true in one of the
exhibits a phone interview tasha states
here's my thing all of these strippers
are lying referring to jones cardi and a
third party in that same call tasha
concludes that jones quote told some
truths she didn't tell all truths one of
the most damning pieces of evidence in
this trial was when the court played a
phone call between tasha and celebrity
blogger lovely tea who told tasha that
the information from star marie jones
was fake and she shouldn't repeat the
claims at one point in the trial tasha
conceded that in her deposition she said
it would be funny to claim that cardi b
had hpv quote is it a fact that you
testified in your deposition that you
thought it was funny to say cardi b had
hpv answer yes that definitely does not
put tasha in a very sympathetic light
the jury also found in cardi's favor on
the invasion of privacy and intentional
infliction of emotional distress claims
in georgia a claim for intentional
infliction of emotional distress or ied
has four elements that there was an
intentional or reckless conduct which is
extreme and outrageous
which caused emotional distress which is
severe in support of her ied claim cardi
pointed to a video where tasha says she
had a personal vendetta against cardi
the jury could have found that tasha
therefore had a motive to defame cardi's
character in this case the jury was
probably satisfied that tasha's
statements were extreme and outrageous
however it's possible that this
particular verdict might get overturned
because conduct that can be
characterized as merely vulgar tasteless
rude or insulting generally should not
support a claim for ied now there was
also a cause of action for invasion of
privacy which ironically was the name of
cardi b's debut album georgia has
adopted four forms of invasion of
privacy the one at issue in this case is
invasion of privacy through portrayal in
a false light the elements of that claim
are that the defendant publicized a
matter concerning plaintiff that places
plaintiff in a false light the defendant
acts in a reckless disregard as to the
truth or falsity of the publicized
matter and the false light in which the
the plaintiff would be placed and the
the false light in which the plaintiff
was placed would be highly offensive to
a reasonable person and in support of
her invasion of privacy claim cardi b
emphasized the many times natasha
admitted that her stories were false
when she published them she apparently
was quoted as saying you know what's
funny i make up stories out of thin air
tasha just makes up stories she also
said i knew it was fake i still made
that stuff go
viral anyway
so that was probably more than enough to
win on that particular invasion of
privacy claim now as for the damages
that cardi b is able to recover in this
case the jury awarded cardi 1 million
dollars in general damages for the
reputational damages she experienced in
georgia actual damages explicitly
include impairment of reputation and
standing in the community cardi's
complaint alleged that some of tasha's
statements were defamation per quoad and
others were defamation per se defamation
per se are statements which are
considered to be so harmful on their
face that the plane doesn't need to
prove special damages uh tasha accused
cardi of having stis working as a
prostitute committing lewd acts with a
beer bottle and all of these statements
likely qualify as defamation per se so
cardi didn't have to prove damages to
win on liability and many of cardi's
trial exhibits presented proof that she
incurred medical expenses because of
emotional distress
cardi b testified that she considered
suicide experience anxiety weight loss
depression and migraines she also said
it impacted her relationship with her
husband offset now
tasha accused cardi of having herpes
pointing to a photograph of a mark on
her lip
people started to comment about it on
cardi's social media posts and when
cardi b posted a photo of her kissing
her daughter people commented that she
was going to give her kid herpes
cardi b said it had a serious impact on
her mental health and she sought
treatment with a therapist because of
the ordeal the therapist dr sherry blake
said that during the two years she
treated cardi her mental health
deteriorated because tasha would not
stop badgering her with these claims
on top of that cardi was awarded 1.5
million dollars in punitive damages
after the jury found tasha liable for
defamation the lawyers offered evidence
regarding punitive damages and attorneys
fees and costs each side had 20 minutes
to present evidence but tasha's lawyers
who are criminal defense lawyers only
took 90 seconds the jury awarded cardi
an additional 2.8 million dollars in
punitive damages and attorneys fees
georgia allows punitive damages in
defamation cases under certain
circumstances punitive damages are given
solely to punish or penalize or deter a
defendant and to prove those damages a
plaintiff must show that the defendant's
actions showed willful misconduct malice
fraud wantedness or oppression if the
defendant demonstrated total disregard
for the consequences of her actions a
jury can impose punitive damages to
punish that defendant and a plaintiff
must prove this by clear and convincing
evidence which is higher than the
preponderance standard that you're
usually dealing with in a civil case
though there is a 250 000 cap on
punitive damages in georgia unless the
plaintiff can prove specific intent to
cause harm the jury deliberated for two
hours before deciding that cardi b had
proved that tasha intended to cause harm
now there's also some really interesting
inside baseball here involving toshike
and her lawyers
cardi b filed suit against tasha k and
tasha k also filed counter claims for
assault and iid so effectively within
the same case she sued cardi b she
asserted that cardi deliberately got her
fans riled up by falsely claiming that
tasha was stalking cardi and her friends
and making up fake stories she also said
that cardi called her names like dumbass
[ __ ] and ho tasha also said that when
cardi threatened to bankrupt tasha by
stating quote and i'm quoting here uh
all right then [ __ ] i'm gonna take all
your [ __ ] bread she meant that she
was going to get violent tasha said
cardi's fans then made verbal threats
and she was forced to move several times
because of the fans the judge dismissed
these counter claims because tasha
couldn't prove that cardi b herself had
threatened tasha or made her believe
that she was going to harm her and
although fans made lots of threats there
was no evidence that cardi communicated
with any of these people let alone that
she asked them to take action against
tasha and the iid counterclaim failed
for the same reasons even if tasha
suffered emotional distress because
cardi's fans behaved in an extreme and
outrageous manner tasha couldn't prove
causation from cardi b since there
wasn't any evidence that cardi committed
these acts that she directed others to
harass and intimidate tasha the claim
was dismissed before trial and many
people including tasha had criticism
for tasha's lawyers many news outlets
concluded that tasha's lawyer olga
ismailova was not prepared for trial and
had no experience in defamation claims
ismailova is primarily a criminal
defense lawyer her cross-examination of
cardi took barely an hour the judge told
her to go back to law school and
curiously tasha reviewed ismailova back
in june of 2021 shortly after the court
dismissed her counterclaims according to
the website avvo which is a very
mainstream place to rate lawyers
tasha gave her lawyer one star out of
five saying quote will not use this
attorney again one star posted by
latasha kaby june 5th 2021 very
disappointed with his attorney i hired
her to represent me in a defamation case
but i will have to seek another attorney
olga has on several occasions shown up
to court unprepared and unfamiliar with
the facts of the case she advised me to
file a countersuit which i did but it is
clear now that that was not the best
move after advising me to counter sue
she then doubled back and dropped
several counts on the countersuit so why
did she advise me to file it in the
first place at the last hearing she was
stuttering and tripping over her words
and it was embarrassing an attorney is
supposed to exude confidence in their
client but it's like she is not fighting
to win the case she's just going through
the motions and showing up to court
after paying her thousands of dollars
over the past three years this case has
been dragging on i'm no better off i'm
counting my losses and moving on i will
not be using this attorney again
so there's no guarantee that tasha k
actually was the one that wrote this and
posted this to avvo but it sounds pretty
genuine but it does raise the question
why would she continue with this lawyer
through trial if she had these
criticisms but passing judgment on
tasha's lawyer is beyond the scope of
this video and i'll say that sometimes
lawyers are bad and sometimes lawyers
just have to deal with the client that
they have not the client that they wish
they had but now the judge is probably
going to order toshike to take down the
offending youtube videos and it's
possible that youtube might just delete
her channel for breaking the law so
since she'll probably have to start over
she could really benefit from mkbhd's
class youtube success script shoot and
edit with mkbhd on today's sponsor
skillshare if she takes that class
she'll learn how to plan a video that's
true to her but also widely appealing
and also just you know true
shoot compelling content with whatever
gear she has edit the footage to grab
attention and grow her channel
strategically while still having fun and
presumably
not breaking the law because skillshare
has classes on almost everything from
video to music to business and
entrepreneurship skillshare as you know
is one of the world's largest online
learning communities with tens of
thousands of classes on everything and
it's the best place to get a start on
the internet or if you're tasha k get a
new start and if you'd like to try out
skillshare the first 1000 legal eagles
to use my link in the description will
get a free trial of skillshare premium
and for a limited time that trial is for
an entire month not the normal 14 days
so just click on the link that's on
screen right now or the one that's in
the description to get a free trial of
skillshare premium plus clicking on that
link really helps out this channel and
while you're there click on this other
link with all my other real law reviews
so click on this link or i'll see you in
court